The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today
we have from EA,
Timothy Cowan's going to
give a lecture on development
best practices from
Electronic Arts.
This is about the
time of the class
where we start doing
hour long lectures
and then the remaining two hours
is open for your work time.
It's really going to start
being like that probably not
next Wednesday, but
the following Monday
is when that's going to
be a pretty stable time.
So when you're working
on project four,
you're going to have a lot more
in class time to work in teams.
Hopefully you've been taking
advantage of the class time
to work in your teams
for project three.
Today we are doing play testing.
Has everybody already
prepared for what
they're going to do for
their play test today?
Do you already have
questionnaire, survey, observer
notes, things like that?
I'm seeing some blank faces.
That's OK.
We're going to give you
15 minutes to set that up.
So we're going to do
lecture, take a short break,
then you'll get 15 minutes to
prepare for the focus test.
We're asking you to set
up three workstations
for the test at all times.
I'll go through the details
when we start that up.
But you'll get a little bit of
time to set up for play test.
Remember, we're asking
for two focus test
reports for project three.
This is going to
count for one of them.
The other one you need
to do on your own time
or have already done.
Grading is practically
finished for project two.
And now it's just entering
it all into the Stellar form,
and you'll have all
that by tomorrow night.
What I can say just in
general for grading,
project two looked pretty good.
Most of the games completed
all of the requirements.
The main requirements
that we saw
that were lacking
in some of the games
were really the
legal requirements.
Putting your credits, putting
your names on the game.
We asked for that.
So please make sure you're
doing for project three.
Even if it's not
in the game itself,
it can be on the full sheet,
the full HTML code for the game.
So make sure you're putting
your names on your games
when you're turning them in.
And also if you're
using any outside code,
any outside assets,
that should all
be listed as where
it's coming from
and what license
you have for that.
Phaser is MIT licensed,
so there wasn't
anything special for there.
But if you're using Unity,
take a look at Unity's license
requirements.
Make sure you're
fulfilling them.
If you're using hacks or
Flixel, make sure your filling
those requirements.
I believe we already gave
you some comments on the post
forms.
But for the most part,
those also looked good.
For project three, here's the
cheat sheet for product three's
postmortems.
You've got a page to
write a postmortem.
Make half of it about your
team practices and processes.
The other half about
the game and the design.
That's really what we're
looking for is understanding
how your team organized itself,
what communication problems
you had, how you solved them,
and even more importantly, what
are you going to
do in project four.
Because in product
four, you're going
to have eight
people on your team
and problems are going
to show up more often.
So hopefully you're coming
up with ideas and ways
to be prepared for
those kind of things.
Any other comments?
Otherwise for the other
turn ins for product two,
task lists were good.
Backlogs were acceptable.
The focus test reports
for the most acceptable.
We give you some comments
about your focus test reports.
We gave you some comments
about your design change logs.
We also are giving you
a big chunk of comments
about the game design.
It's going to be labeled
not part of the grade.
So like I said, it's
not a design class,
but we do want to give you
some feedback on your designs.
So we can help you out
with future assignments.
That's it.
Any questions about anything?
Great.
So I'm just going to
hand it off to Tim.
TIM COWAN: Great.
So can everybody hear me?
Sound good?
You can just raise your hand in
the back if you can't hear me.
Good?
All right.
So let me start off a little
bit with just introductions.
Who I am, my background, where I
came from, why I'm here, maybe.
I'm actually originally
from Oklahoma.
I was born in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
And went to Oklahoma
State University.
And going to
university, I actually
had no idea what I wanted to do.
Kind of just sort of landed at
one of the in state tuitions
for university.
But I knew my dad was an
engineer, a programmer
specifically, and I
kind of thought that I
wanted to go do what he did.
So I went into
university, was going
to go be trained
to be a programmer.
He actually gave me advice to go
work on more pure engineering.
And so for my
undergraduate degree,
I was actually focused on
mechanical engineering.
And I stayed at Oklahoma
State University
and went on to
aerospace engineering.
Did graduate school.
Was in pursuit of a Ph.D.
with ultimately the goal
I wanted to be an astronaut.
I didn't make it there.
I made video games today.
But I did get a chance to
through graduate school
work on research for
Dryden Flight Research
Center in California and
actually spent about 10 months
there as a visiting researcher
while I was working on my Ph.D.
And what I did for them was what
I'd say were flight simulators.
But not that kind
of flight simulator.
It was more this kind
Computer simulation of aircraft.
I did a lot of both the
simulation of the aircraft
and generating visual
representations
of the simulations.
And ultimately out of all that
work I did finish my Ph.D.
and sort of officially
became a rocket scientist.
And so then I had to decide
what I wanted to go do.
And my plan really was
to go work at Lockheed,
design aircraft, work on
flight simulators for them.
That was basically my life's
mission coming out of college.
But that didn't
quite happen either
and I ended up at EA Sports.
So instead of working on
flight simulators, what
I've done for the
last 14 years is work
on NFL football simulators.
A recruiter from EA
just basically blind
contacted me from my resume
posting on Monster.com
and they brought me
down to Austin, Texas
to work on my first
video game, which
was Madden NFL 2002 for the PC.
There was a small team in
Austin of about six people
that built this product
off of a shared code
base from the PlayStation
to Xbox and Game Cube.
And I spent about
18 months in Austin.
Built two versions of
Madden PC in that time,
until they eventually
moved me out
to Florida, which was where
Tiburon Entertainment was
located, one of the
studios that's part of EA
and part of EA Sports.
And I've been there,
really been with Tiburon
for I guess it's
counting 13 years now.
And in that span
one of the things
I'm most proud of is I
built 14 versions of Madden
in that time.
And I can say, with the
exception of Madden 15,
because my roles changed, I've
contributed at least one line
of code to 13 versions of
Madden over the last 13 years.
Things are pretty
different at Tiburon
from when I started in 2001.
There were about 200 people
at the studio when I started.
There are 700 at
our location today.
We work on three
different products.
And I'm the group technical
director for the studio.
So I help make sure that all
three of the products we build
succeeds and sort of monitoring
engineering and technology
development for the studio.
Our three products
are obviously Madden.
We build NBA Live
and we're working
on the next generation
of PGA Tour Golf, which
will be out this March.
So that's my background.
A little bit about my role.
It is very much it is an
engineering leadership role
as a group technical director.
And I very much don't
write much code.
In fact, I kind of joke
with the other engineers
that the coding that I do
is PowerPoint these days.
Let's talk a little
bit about Madden.
Set a little bit of
context about some
of the philosophy
and best practices
that I hope to a kind
of pass along today.
Madden in North America
has been a we'll call it
a top five product for at least
the last 15 years, typically
is a top three product
in North America.
Generally the first person
shooters are the big sellers,
especially in North America.
Sometimes you've got
some of the action games
like Grand Theft Auto.
But depending on what's being
released at any given year,
Madden's always a number two,
number three in North American
sales.
And you can see FIFA top
10 North American sales.
They're a different sort
of a sports product.
That is the big sports product
but they have global appeal,
because the sport
has global appeal
and it sells in a lot of
markets that Madden does not.
But as a North American company,
Electronic Arts, the number two
title in North America.
In fact, on that last
chart, the number one title
in North America that
EA sold is Madden.
And it's very important to EA.
It's very important
to EA stock price.
If you look at any sort of
financial reports or just
even news briefs on
financial listings for EA,
you'll often see that the little
blurb at the bottom where they
kind of describe who
Electronic Arts is, Madden's
almost always listed as
Electronic Arts, developer
of products such as
Madden, Battlefield, FIFA.
Madden is very important to EA.
And the success or
failure of that product
is very important to the
public company's stock price.
If you look at
Madden development,
given its importance
to the company,
given the size of its
sales, it's a big team.
There's over 200
developers on staff
that do direct
development on Madden.
That includes engineers,
artists, designers, producers,
product managers, quality
assurance testers.
And there are additional
developers that
contribute through central.
Technology We're a
very large organization
that contributes in a
lot of different ways.
But sort of at our studio
we call it 200 people
doing direct dev on Madden.
10 million lines of
code, give or take a few.
That's physical lines of codes.
So it includes white
space and comments
and those kinds of things.
But a lot, a lot of code to look
at across 150,000 plus files.
And we do development
distributed across four
different locations.
So we've got primary
development in Orlando,
but we also have
remote development
in Austin and a contract company
that we work with Nova Scotia.
And Vancouver is the sibling
studio for Sports, EAC,
who makes FIFA, NHL, USC.
They contribute a lot
of central technology
that helps ship
Madden each year.
So there's really
sort of four locations
that we're distributed across.
Really the message
here is Madden's big.
It's a big seller.
It has big importance.
And it's big large
scale development.
Large teams, large code
bases, large complexity.
And the other
characteristic about
is kind of important
to sort of understand
sort of the nature of this
project, this big project that
also iterates at an iterative
cycle every single year.
So our sports products come
out at the start of the sports
season every single year.
And it's critical that Madden
comes out on its date in August
when the NFL season kicks off.
Our gamers expect it.
Our shareholders
expect it to sell.
And if you miss that
start of the NFL season
and were to, say,
slip your ship date,
that means a lot of lost
opportunity in terms
of delighting our gamers.
That's very different from
other types of game development.
Like certain games, they're
done when they're done.
And even within EA we
do this a little bit.
This was one of
the announcements
we made about Mirrors Edge.
That's not Madden.
Madden can never miss its date.
And it has come out in
August for the last 25 years
consistently and reliably.
So given that context, what I
want to talk about a little bit
first is just some philosophy.
And this is some philosophy I've
come to over the past couple
years about what I think
makes a good engineer at EA
and specifically on Madden
and our sports products.
What some of the mindset
then things that you
may need to break
out of in order
to be successful doing
development on the big title
that's got to come out
on a particular date.
And when you are big
title and a big team
and a complicated project that
has to hit a particular date,
the first thing
that happens is we
go add a lot of really
complicated process.
Because there's a
lot of moving parts.
Everything's got to get tracked.
And if anything
slips, then we're
not going to hit our date.
You add a lot of checklists
and you check things off.
Hopefully get
everything checked off.
But the reality is there's
always a lot of work to do.
We've got 200 plus
people doing a lot
of different types of work and
you only have about one year
to get work done.
And we want to do
and put as much
as we possibly can into that
product every single year.
Because if nothing
else, I know I'm
very sensitive to
our sports products.
Because they come
out every year,
we tend to get beat up a little
bit over just a roster update.
They haven't done enough.
There's not enough improvements
over last year's product.
Well we do a lot of work and
we want to do a lot of work
to make sure that every single
year we're putting out the best
possible product that we can.
And it's not just us.
Also our gamers
really want-- they're
giving us a lot of feedback.
We want this, let's
get this feature in,
Madden would be better
if you just did this.
So there's a lot of work
and our kind of human nature
is let's do it all.
We're going to get
it all done, we're
going to ship an
amazing product,
and we're going to get it
all done on time in August.
Well if you take on too much
and you try to do everything,
disaster happens inevitably.
And one thing we have
to remember in sports
is development's a
multi-year journey.
It's a path.
Most game products,
especially if you're
looking at a open world action
adventure game or first person
shooter, they tend to have
two if not three or four
years of development.
We kind of start to think
about Madden development
in that same way where
it's a three year
process with incremental
releases along the way, where
the game just keeps getting
better and better and better
on a three year roadmap.
And it's important in
this sense because I
think all game makers want
to do everything, want
to make the game as
amazing as they can.
But in sports, you really
have to embrace iteration.
And that means kind of finding
the right balance between doing
everything, doing
everything right,
and especially if you're
an engineer remembering
that sometimes you have
to balance between getting
everything done right and maybe
using some duct tape and kind
of hacking in a quick solution.
Because you've got
three years to make sure
that you're getting things done
on that road that you're on.
So another idea I'd like to
talk a little bit about, again,
just more philosophy
about engineering.
I talk about the
difference between science
and engineering.
And I'm going to sort of give
the extreme examples and maybe
overgeneralize things.
But one of things I talk
about to my engineers
is, if you look at science,
science at its core
is about the pursuit
of knowledge.
The idea is king.
You're going to try to
figure out how things work.
You don't know what you're going
to do once you find it out.
But just the fact that
I know how that works,
I know this idea, that's
what's most important.
Engineering, on the other
hand, if sort of like the best
engineer, if you're just the
extreme engineer, the thing
you get the most
excitement out of his
taking that knowledge
from the scientists
and figuring out how to apply
it to solve practical problems.
And cost effective
solutions is definitely
one of the keys in terms of
that well rounded engineer that
goes in and is figuring
out how to solve
a very practical
problem based on a body
of scientific knowledge.
It's really important
for engineers
remember that there are
solutions to even the hardest
problems.
If cost is a factor,
you often find
that engineers will tend to
say this type of problem's
not possible.
But what they really mean is
it's very, very expensive.
But engineers need to
really be focused on,
how do you break down
a problem and come up
with a solution to that problem?
And sometimes it's duct tape.
And for the Star
Trek fans out there,
remember there are no unwinnable
scenarios in engineering.
There is no Mission Impossible.
I've had engineers on
Madden in particular
where Madden in the
early Xbox 360 generation
actually ran at 30
frames per second.
And there were a few
years there where
we were told it was
impossible for Madden
to run at 60 frames per second.
And so in a leadership
position, a lot of your job
is to kind of break through
that this is impossible
and start to ask
questions on how can we
break this problem down
and come up with some cost
effective solutions
that will actually
allow us to solve this problem.
And at the end of
the day, you're
not going to solve problems
if you don't attack them
with enthusiasm.
And so my
encouragement is really
to challenge the impossible.
Everything is possible.
It maybe might not
be possible today.
It might not be
possible with the money
you've got in your wallet.
But given enough time and
money, we can do anything.
And every problem can be solved.
At least at the
core, a good engineer
really needs to believe that.
So let's go on next idea.
And I want to dispel the
myth of perfect code.
Because this is
one of those things
that engineers coming into EA,
really coming into any job,
have this myth that
there is perfect code.
Because engineers
love perfect code.
And they really love to
argue about perfect code.
Even the best engineers
in the world, this
is ingrained into every
engineer that not only is there
perfect code, I know what
that perfect code looks like
and I'm the only
one that writes it.
But the reality is,
mistakes are always made.
It tends to be the first
time you write code,
especially if it's
the first time
you've written code for
a problem you've ever
solved before.
You're going to make mistakes.
And I do very much
fundamentally believe
that kind of at the core
inside that you learn more
from mistakes.
Hopefully you guys
have heard that before.
And if you never make any
mistakes, you're not learning.
And if you're never taking
on really big potentially
impossible challenges,
you're not learning.
You're not stretching
yourself, you're not growing.
So it's important to remember
that mistakes will be made.
You're going to learn from those
mistakes, and you know what?
Your code will get better
as you make those mistakes
and refine it.
So remember, there is a
software development life cycle.
And in fact, a lot
of times when you're
arguing about perfect code,
it's very early on in the cycle
and you don't even
know what you don't
know because that code hasn't
been through that software
development life cycle.
There's almost no guarantee that
there's no bugs in this code
that you're writing.
And it really isn't until you
make it through that software
life cycle that you're going to
understand what those bugs are.
Towards the end of
the project where
you have this
perfect code and all
of a sudden now it's been
all the way through testing
and certification and now you
see, oops, I made a mistake.
And when you tie that into
our sports iterative cycle
where we're embracing iteration,
taking on the impossible,
one of the big things that
try to impress on people
is try to value less
the perfect code
and start to think
about proven code.
Proven code that's been through
that software development life
cycle, has had the
bugs shaken out of it.
Even if you didn't
write it, that code
is proven and will have less
bugs typically than code
that you go right from scratch.
And then the next idea,
and this is the last one
before we can get
onto the other section
and get out of the philosophy
stuff, is on a big team,
on that iterative cycle
there's a lot of tasks.
There's a lot of
work to get done.
Everybody's given
their tasks and they
have to finish their tasks.
They've all kind of got this
little piece of a puzzle
and they own their
piece of the puzzle.
They've been given
this task and they're
going to get that piece done.
And it's going to be perfect
given the context that they've
been given on that task.
The trick is there's
a lot of dependencies.
And it's often very
hard to go see,
how do all those
pieces together?
And when you've got
this kind of situation,
you start to end up with you've
got these features, which are
actually a collection of tasks.
And those features don't
really have an owner.
All the tasks have an owner.
Someone's doing the tasks.
But what about the feature?
Does the feature have an owner?
Does anybody know
how all those pieces
are going to fit together?
And if you don't have
someone owning that feature,
you end up with
unfinished projects.
Or potentially you
end up with not quite
what you were looking for
because you didn't really
understand from this task
how it all fit together
and was going to ultimately
deliver whatever it
was that we were looking for.
And so it's super
important when you
get immersed into
a really big team
and you're hand and
a bunch of tasks
to pick your head up
every once in a while
and make sure that you're
focused on that feature.
And potentially
you're asking, how
does this task that I'm working
on fit into this feature?
Because if you've got that
context, you may even realize,
hey, my task
actually isn't going
to help me deliver
on that feature.
I'm not working on
the right thing.
As an engineer with a
technical background,
I'm building good software,
functional requirements,
et cetera.
You really need to be
focusing on that feature.
Because your task
is just a means
to delivering on that feature.
So in summary, just a little
bit of philosophy type stuff.
Embrace iteration.
Challenge the impossible.
Value proven code and focus
on features, not tasks.
And that's kind of my top four.
It's easily a top 10 list.
The thing is to
kind of think about
in terms of coming into a big
company, working on a big team.
Some of the philosophy that you
kind of need to take with you
in your approach on
integrating with that team
and being successful.
Now I want to talk a little
bit about more on the process
side, engineering quality.
How do we as a engineering
organization at the studio help
make sure that we're
delivering a quality product.
And game development's
notoriously not very formal.
We are game
developers, after all.
The challenge, though,
when you're not
terribly formal in your
development methodologies
and your development
practices is success
starts to rely on individual
heroics or individual heroism.
And that's a bit
of a danger zone
when you start talking
about shipping a quality
product that's big and on time.
Because quality's
never an accident.
I love this quote.
It's never an accident.
It's the result of
intelligent effort.
Now, before we talk
about processes for this,
let's decompose
quality a little bit.
Because this kind of plays
into some of the thinking
on our approach to quality.
And really, it's going to
focus on the different aspects
of quality.
There's perceptual quality.
Is the game fun?
Is it beautiful?
It's how the gamer
experiences the game.
There's functional quality.
That's kind of, does it work?
An engineer is given
a spec and writes code
and it either does or does not
do what it was intended to do.
And then there's
structural quality.
That's the underlying,
behind the scenes quality.
It tends to be the
type of quality
that engineers care
about the most.
That's kind of the
code quality space.
Is my code perfect?
The top two perceptual quality,
functional quality, those
are things that the gamer is
going to see in your product.
Structural quality
is not something
that the gamer will
actually ever see or notice.
But it is something that
will hold up your project.
If you don't have the right
level of structural quality
in your product,
it will prevent you
from delivering that product.
Now ultimately, at
the end of the day
we're probably most interested
in that perceptual quality.
Because that's the
one that's most
going to resonate
with the gamers.
Is it fun?
Is it beautiful?
And we kind of
like it meta critic
as one possible measure of
whether our game's being
perceived as a high quality.
This is basically a reviewer
sits down, plays the game,
or even if you go
look at user reviews.
A gamer sits down
and plays the game.
And then that game
experience gets
processed through
their filters and they
perceive it to be at a
certain level of quality.
Now, functional
quality is inevitably
going to play into this.
But we generally see, I
think, with meta critic
is a lot of the
functional issues may not
be seen because it takes hours
and hours and hours of playing
the game before
those maybe surfaced.
And it tends to be,
especially with meta critic,
you spend four to eight
hours playing the game,
you process that
experience, give it a score.
So I tend to kind of
argue, at least when
we're talking internally
about quality, only
the absolute worst
functional issues are
going to show up and play
into your meta critic score.
But the gamer who plays
your game for 100 plus hours
is really going to notice a
lot of those functional quality
issues.
We also have been
talking recently
about kind of a
spectrum of quality.
And this is kind of
tied to meta critic.
And I steal this from one
of our executive producers
where from 0 to about 69,
those games are sort of just
foundationally solid.
If you're anywhere below
69, sort of the upper end
of that spectrum.
You get to about 69 or 70 by
being foundationally solid.
Anything below that, you're
buggy, you're broken,
you've got a lot of issues.
And from there,
quality kind of builds.
If you're buggy, broken, and
have just glaring problems,
you're never going to
get to that next level
where you've got good function.
It functions and if you have
a competitor in the space,
it functions at least as
well as the competitor.
And that's kind of
that 70 to 79 range.
But what we really want to do
is we want to get up above that.
This is interactive
entertainment.
We're trying to really delight
the gamers that play our game.
And from 80 to 89,
we kind of start
to talk about, all right,
that's the point where
your game is getting immersive.
Especially for Madden, it's
starting to be very realistic
and they feel like they're
there on Sunday watching a game
and they're sort of
immersed in the experience.
And then even above
that, which is
where we really want to get
to is 90 to 99 or even 100.
I don't know if it
actually goes to 100.
But that's where
now not only are
you immersed in the
experience, but the game
is evoking emotion.
So when you get up
into those upper bands,
that's where perceptual quality
really starts to come in.
I'm going to talk
a little bit more
about that foundational and
that functional quality,
because that's what engineers
and development directors are
ultimately paid to solve.
And so the question
is, on a big project
with a lot of complexity that's
got to hit a particular date,
inevitably need to
put a lot of process
in place to try to do make
sure that you're putting out
that quality product or
at least at a minimum
were able to hit that
foundational and functional
quality so that the
designers and everyone
else can help push us up
into those perceptual realms.
The first process
is code review.
So let's talk a little
bit about code review.
Because engineers
love code review.
Especially because
their code is perfect
and no one needs to
look at this code
to figure out whether
or not it should
be allowed to get checked in.
At EA and on Madden
in particular,
we do have a blanket policy,
all code gets reviewed.
If you're going to check code
in, it's got to get reviewed.
We even in this day
and age where data
is a huge part of development.
Actually there's a lot of
data that gets reviewed
before it gets checked in.
But code review is sort
of the primary function
where all right, you're
going to check in code.
It needs to get reviewed.
And the goal there, let's
make sure there's no bugs.
Get a second set of eyes,
have someone look at it.
Shake out all the bugs.
Because the second set of eyes
will find the bugs before it
makes it to QA.
There was an interesting
study recently, Rebel Labs.
They did a survey and
asked development teams,
how many of you do code
review and how often
do you code review?
Code review is very
prevalent coming out
from this industry survey.
I think it was 76% of teams
do a lot of code review.
And their ultimate
goal with this survey
was to figure out the impact
of code review on quality.
And quality for them was
defined by lack of bugs.
So the functional
realm of quality.
And their study produced kind
of an interesting result.
They were actually looking
at two factors, quality
and predictability.
Both super important for sports.
And they found that
code review really
helped with predictability.
It indexed well.
You could see if you did no code
review, there was an 11% or 10%
swing between no code review
and always doing code review.
Much less influence
though on quality.
They found that there
was not actually
not much of a difference between
teams that did code review
and didn't do code review
in the span of quality.
Again, quality is
measured as bugs.
AUDIENCE: What is
predictability?
TIMOTHY COWAN: Predictability
is able to hit your schedule
on time.
Now, that's not to say that we
don't find bugs in code review.
But I think that's interesting
because it kind of aligns
with some of my experience
within EA that, now, don't get
me wrong, we put code
review in place because we
wanted to find bugs early.
And when I started at EA we
did not do any code review.
In 2001, again, this is
kind of individual heroics,
pretty informal.
On a 200 person team, you've
got to do code review.
And we do want to find bugs.
But it's actually
a little surprising
that we don't find many
bugs in code review.
And I see that at
our studio as well.
How many people here know C++?
All right.
Awesome.
Let's play a little
game quick here.
It's called find the bug.
You guys are code reviewers.
Raise your hand if
you can spot the bug.
There is a bug here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY COWAN: You can't see it?
OK.
Is it the contrast
or the lights?
Anybody that can see it spot it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY COWAN: Good.
Good.
That is the mistake.
It's a cut and paste error.
So someone moving fast.
And it tends to be pretty
easy not to notice this.
It's just kind of hidden
in a block of code.
It actually was
intended in this case.
It's just kind of following
a pretty simple pattern.
They should have been copying
PURL into the STR web URL.
This was code that was written,
tested by the engineer that
wrote it, I presume.
Code reviewed, checked in, and
made it all the way out to QA.
I don't know if an
actual bug manifested,
but this code did make
it through code review.
In fact, all this code
we're going to look at
made it through code review.
How about this one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY COWAN: All right.
Yeah.
That is kind of the trick with
code is it's kind of tiny text.
[LAUGHTER]
It's probably the sunlight.
People in the front
row can see it?
No?
I guess this game's
a little less fun
than maybe I was hoping.
In this case, you've
got two different files
and this is a function call.
And there's one
line of code where
they're using the function.
In the second file,
if you're doing
a code review you've actually
got to-- in this case,
someone added a line of code.
And when you get
that code review,
you get just that file
with a little diff
and you see their line
of code that they added.
You won't actually
spot this blog
unless you open
up the other file
that they didn't edit and
go look at that function
and how it's used.
Because they've actually got
the two parameters reversed.
They're both bools.
Track actives versus
track passives.
And the function they're
calling has those two parameters
reversed.
Again, written, tested,
code reviewed, checked in.
I don't know if this
one's readable at all.
I kind of have to
skip through this.
In the interest of time,
I'll go ahead and just
skip through these.
Because I think they're all
somewhat fuzzy and small text.
In this case, if you don't know
C++ or don't know the syntax,
with that indentation there's
an if statement there.
With the indentation
it was probably
expected that that
code would only
get it executed if the
if condition was true.
They missed their curly braces.
And that that
indentation tends to,
if you're reviewing the
code, kind of draw your eye.
It's like, yeah,
that code looks OK.
You're kind of inspecting it.
And I'm sure that they
knew what they were doing.
And you kind of missed that
the braces aren't there.
And this one's maybe-- no.
So in this case,
their if statement,
it's actually a constant number.
This will always be true.
And they probably actually
meant to check if that value was
equal to some particular value.
But they actually just
put the mask right
into the if statement.
And that will always
be a number greater
than 0, which will be true.
And last one.
This last statement here.
This last statement
doesn't do anything.
They're just assigning
one variable to itself.
Again, really easy
cut and paste errors.
And I think the surprising
thing in a lot of cases, again,
we've got this process.
We do find bugs.
But you don't find all of them.
And a lot a really simple ones,
things that after the fact,
when you get a bug report from
QA and you go look at that
and you're like, how
come no one caught this?
How come the person that
wrote it didn't catch it?
How come the code
reviewer didn't catch it?
I'll tell you, in some
cases it's not even
just one person code reviewing,
but you may have five people
that code review it.
Again, we're big,
multi-disciplinary.
Sometimes one check in may take
five different subject matter
experts where I need
a rendering engineer,
I need a physics engineer,
and I need a UI engineer
to review this code.
And five different people review
the code and no one catches
the problem.
But there are other
reasons for code review.
And this is one of the
things I'm pretty adamant on.
Because when that report
comes out that says,
code review doesn't
really find bugs.
And in fact, if you
don't do code review,
you're not all that bad off
in terms of finding bugs.
I say, wait a minute.
We're not going to stop
our code review process.
Because there's other reasons
for doing code review.
And finding bugs is actually,
I would call, my fourth reason.
Really, code review's about
monitoring structural quality.
And that's why that report
says if you do code review,
you get better predictability.
Because your
structural quality is
this underlying quality
that's going to help you
be successful.
It's going to help with
your predictability.
knock-on effects, where
if you write code that's
consistent, reliable, robust,
and file certain
programming patterns,
you're going to end up with a
better result in the long term
and you'll be more predictable.
It's also about
knowledge sharing.
So on a big team
of 150 people where
everyone's got their
own little task
and they own their
little task, we
need to make sure that
the whole team has
some insight into what all the
other developments are doing.
And if you're out sick
or you win the lottery
and stop working, someone else
at the company's has maybe
done some code reviews and
has seen what you're doing
and has learned from that and
knows about how that feature,
how that task works.
And then it's also
about education.
So if you are the best
engineer on the planet,
you've been writing
code for 14 years,
and you've learned
from all your mistakes,
and you write the most perfect
code, having a new engineer who
just came to work
at the studios,
is writing their
first line of code
ever review your code teaches
that person something.
And then the last point
is obviously catch bugs.
We do want to catch bugs
through code review.
It's just it's not the
only thing that you get out
of code review.
And really, static analysis
and rigorous testing
is the best way to catch bugs.
And in fact, all those
examples I just went through
are caught by static
analysis that we apply
to our code base every day.
Static analysis today is
actually very good at pattern
matching and identifying
those types of issues.
And on a code base our
size, you see a lot of them.
And static analysis is
actually a very important
additional process, I'm not
going to talk a lot about that,
to layer into a robust
development process.
All right, so the next piece.
All right, if we
want to find bugs
we want to drive
functional quality,
we need quality testing.
And your game
development's messy.
You're never going
to find all the bugs.
And really testing is
only good to find bugs.
No matter how much
testing you do,
you're never going
to know what bugs
you haven't found, obviously.
So we've got to make
sure we do testing.
And there's a lot of
different types of testing.
There's the engineer doing
their own software testing.
There's our QA department
who does black box testing.
There's automated testing.
There's a whole
spectrum of testing
that we do on our
product to help
make sure that the product
we put out is amazing.
But inevitably, game
development's messy.
No matter what we do,
things do slip out.
In fact, in the first 48
hours of Madden launching,
there is more testing done
on our product by the gamers
than we do an entire 10 month
development cycle by ourselves.
So one of the big processes
we have in place today
is test automation.
You can't hire enough QA
people to test your game
for the scale and the size of
games and complexity of games
today.
So we do lots and lots
of test automation.
And basically the goal is to
get hours and hours and hours
of testing through automation
on hundreds of dev kits
that sit idle at the studio at
night when people are at home.
There's one big
piece that I want
to talk about with
test automation, which
is when we talk to
engineering, verification,
and validation,
testing is a means
to compare the execution,
the results of the test
against the expected
results for that test.
And one thing that we're
starting to do a lot more at EA
is we're kind of
looking at testing where
automated testing in particular
where kind of the only expected
result is that the
test completes.
That test may take five minutes.
It may take 50 minutes.
All we're doing is looking,
hey, did that test complete.
And within that span
of say 50 minutes,
there's all kinds of
other things that went on.
And we're not really testing
whether all those things
between here and here met
what our expected results are.
So really, this is about
measurement and functional
quality measurement, which
starts with technical KPIs.
Over a 50 minute test, did
the game run at frame rate?
What are the load times
between your different modes?
Did they meet what our
expected requirements were?
Obviously there's crashes,
desyncs, and disconnects,
which are very abrupt
failures for that test where
it won't actually complete.
But there's all these
other technical KPIs
where the test will
continue, but it may not
have been doing what
you'd expect it to do.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY COWAN: So what we're
starting to do more now
is measure and make sure that
every build so that every test
where an automated
test, no one's
sitting there watching it.
I may not know.
If a QA person doesn't sit there
and watch that automated test,
we don't know that it's not
running at target frame rate
unless we measure
it and report it.
And with online
services today, you
can do a lot of measuring
and automated reporting,
capture all that data,
and create dashboards
that can show, all right, what's
the performance of my Game
this is one the first ones we
put in over the last couple
years.
We've always had
performance analysis.
But what we now have
is automated solutions
with very detailed
level of reports,
so that every time
someone plays our game,
we're getting frame rate
reports out of that game.
And you can drill down a little
bit to look at for Madden
by stadium.
Every game that's been
played in each stadium, what
does the frame rate look like?
And look and see are
there certain stadiums
that have problems.
And you can even look
at an individual session
and say, all right, was there
an individual game session
that had a strange
frame rate problem?
Now beyond our technical
KPIs, those key performance
indicators, there's other
types of functional issues
that we need to look to measure.
Bugs do slip out into the wild.
This was one that got a
lot of publicity this year,
the tiny titan.
UFC had some well known
glitches in its game
where a lot of funny animation
and physics problems.
Inevitably when
these types of things
happen, if you're familiar with
the notion of asserts, sort
of non fatal errors or
warnings that engineers put
into their code to catch non
fatal problems and warn them
that, hey, you might
want to look at this.
I guarantee when both of those
problems showed up in a debug
build, an assert probably
would've yelled at a developer
and m, hey, something's wrong.
So there's this class of non
fatal functional problems
that are pretty severe, because
if they get out into the wild,
this breaks the immersion and
ability to experience emotion
when you play the game.
Or at least in some
cases, this one's
probably a negative emotion.
We need to start to
shift our focus on as you
build engineering systems.
This is, again, as an engineer,
what you bring to the table
is this methodology and process
of verifying and validating
against functional requirements.
Make sure as you're
building your features,
you're thinking about
testing and you're
thinking about measuring.
Is this doing what
it's supposed to do?
Because I've got a code base
of 10 million lines of code,
200 people contributing to it.
There's a lot of complexity.
And you never know throughout
that software development life
cycle what types of
problems might show up.
So as you're going into your
design and requirements,
start thinking about what
types of failure modes
are critical that I should
be measuring and reporting
through online systems.
We're starting to do a lot
more of this at our studio.
So in summary, we really talked
about two things, code review
and testing.
And specifically measurement
when you're doing that testing.
But it's really about,
for me, an engineer's
responsible for
driving the functional
quality of a product.
We write the code, we
write the specifications.
We have to drive the functional
quality of game software.
And a well executed project
has both the technology
and processes in place
to do that and make sure
that you're able to
take that big project
and get it done by
August every single year.
So that's it.
I think I maybe talked a little
bit longer than I originally
expected.
But we've got a
little bit of time
for Q&A. I think I was told
you guys take a break at 2:00.
But you can go ahead
and ask any questions
and I'll answer anything I can.
When we take the
break, if one on one
if you want to ask
more questions,
I'll probably hang around
while you're doing play testing
and can talk more.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY COWAN:
Today it is all C++.
100%.
I did a talk yesterday sort
of to a general audience
about how the
industry's evolved.
There used to be a lot of
assembly language intermixed
with C++.
We don't do that anymore
today on today's consoles.
And there is in data
we do do Lua scripting.
There is ActionScript.
There is shader code and shaders
for graphics programming.
I bucket those more as data.
And they tend to be-- we have a
Lua interpreter that's written
in C++ the can load Lua
data scripts and process it.
We have an ActionScript
interpreter
that loads ActionScript
and processes it.
So generally when I'm talking
the 10 million lines of code,
it's the C++ game engine client.
But it does interact
with other types of code
that we consider data today.
AUDIENCE: So I've been in code
review situation all the way
from [INAUDIBLE]
mostly automated
through some sort of
code tracking system
or commit system where someone's
about to commit something,
[INAUDIBLE], or all the
way to the other end
where someone just grabs me and
makes me look at their screen.
How does that work?
Can you walk us through
how review works?
TIMOTHY COWAN: Sure.
The policy is all
code gets reviewed.
With that kind of
policy, there's
a lot of flexibility in
how the teams actually
implement the process.
But the tool set we give
them, we do have a server.
We actually use a software from
SmartBear called Collaborator.
And when you're going to
submit code to Perforce,
we use Perforce
for source control,
you upload the diffs to
Collaborator and assign
that to a reviewer to
go look at those diffs.
And they can mark it up, put
little bugs and comments,
send it back to you, and you
can kind of go back and forth.
So it's one option.
That's how 90% of the
code review gets done.
But the thing I tell
the teams is you
don't have to do it that way.
In fact, having someone come
to your desk and talk to you
and look at the code
over your shoulder
can, in a lot of cases,
be much higher value.
Because that can
help set some context
on why did you
write it this way,
and you can have a conversation.
So that's an option as well.
And you also have
the flexibility,
depending on the
situation, sometimes
code gets reviewed
after check in.
It doesn't have to get
reviewed prior to check in.
That's kind of up to the teams,
up to the urgency of the check
in, the seniority of the review.
But the request is that
all code gets reviewed.
Again, it kind of hit the
four bullet points on why.
So I guess basically it depends.
It is game
development, so we try
to be a little informal about
it and give you the flexibility
to do the review
the way you see fit.
But provide a lot of tools
and process and formality
kind of through a prescribed
automated system as well.
I think there was a
question in the back.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How much additional
work is for you
to do things like hoarding
the same game to Xbox,
PS1, [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY COWAN: For today's
consoles, Xbox One,
PlayStation 4.
You're really starting to get
to hardware that's converging.
It's becoming more PC like.
Probably the biggest
difference is actually
going to be in the
operating system.
Each of those consoles
has an operating system.
Xbox One ends up being
sort of flavor of Windows.
And PlayStation 4 ends up
being some variety of Linux.
So you've got this
operating system and driver
layer that is different.
But with the way
EA's structured,
obviously we're cross platform.
Madden, when I showed
the charts earlier,
actually shipped on
seven different platforms
that one year for Madden 13.
We've always built
cross platform support.
I characterize it as about
a 70-30 to 80-20 rule, where
the majority of your
code has no idea what
hardware it's running on.
And there's just kind
of this base layer
that interacts
with the operating
system and the drivers and does
what it has to do specifically
for the console.
And so it's call it
80-20 in terms of code
and 80-20 in terms of effort.
So that 20% layer generally gets
built by our central technology
groups, whether it's the base
level rendering layer, the base
level file system layer, the
base level of memory management
layer.
At EA we've got
central technology
where that gets built
centrally and all teams use it.
And then the teams
take that technology
and build their platform
agnostic game on top of it
where it kind of doesn't
care whether it's
Xbox One or PlayStation 4.
But then the other
space that is different
is just really, I'd
say, performance.
Each of the systems has
slightly different bottlenecks
in terms of what's
fast and what's
not, whether it's memory
bandwidth, shader pipelines.
They have slightly different
strengths and weaknesses.
They're tuned differently.
So you tend to have to look
at your content and your data
and structure it
in a way where it's
optimal for the two systems.
In the space of just kind of
art contact, how many polys,
how your textures are
structured and bundled,
how you write your
shaders especially.
There's quite a bit of space,
quite a bit of, I'd say,
platform specific
optimization work
to make sure we're
really taking advantage
of the different
bottlenecks in the system.
AUDIENCE: Why did
you choose to join
[INAUDIBLE] in the first place?
TIMOTHY COWAN: To be
honest, I had no idea
that you could make a
career in video games.
Like I said in the
intro, I wasn't
looking to go work
on video games,
mostly because I didn't
know that you could.
One of the games I played
the most growing up actually
was Madden.
In fact, really football games.
Anywhere from Tecmo Bowl on the
original Nintendo Entertainment
System to Madden on
the Sega Genesis.
I played a lot of NFL
football games growing up.
It was actually the
NFL football games
that I played that got me
interested in the sport
of football versus the
other way around where
I was a fan of the sport
so I played the games.
It was actually the games as
a junior high, high school
student that I really enjoyed
playing those football
games the most and enjoyed
beating my friends at them
if I could.
And so when I got contacted
by the recruiter where
I'm going to go
work at Lockheed,
hey, come work on
the next generation
of interactive entertainment,
make a football simulator,
I was like, well,
that would be great.
I used to love
playing those games
and was really excited about
coming down and getting
to work on some of
the games that I loved
playing when I was younger.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Do know of SB Nation's
"Breaking Madden" series?
And if so, do you have
any opinions on that?
They deliberately set the game
up with extreme characters,
like 90% skill everything
and 0% skill everything.
TIMOTHY COWAN: I did actually.
I think it was probably about
two weeks ago I watched that.
So I do know what
you're talking about.
My opinion, I think
that's awesome.
Madden and EA
Sports, at its core,
is all about
authenticity and realism.
EA Sports, it's in the game.
And we're pretty serious about
that authenticity, realism,
almost to the point
that, it's just
me talking as a
gamer, where we tend
to be a little too serious.
And I kind of like
that kind of stuff
where it's more just
having fun with the game,
which is what it's all about.
And giving, I think, the
content creation tools
in the hands of the
gamers, where you're
starting to see
a lot more gamers
love to create just as
much as they love to play.
And giving them the flexibility
that they can go in do,
it's an open sandbox,
do whatever you want.
We've maybe put a few
walls and barriers around.
But I would love to be
able to put into Madden,
hey, let's tweak the gravity.
Let's really change
up the physics.
Now, the core of madness is
about authenticity in realism.
So there's certain things
that we're not going
to deviate from that core.
But what little
flexibility we can
put in where you can break
Madden and have a little fun.
Because ultimately it's games.
You want to have fun and
that's what you want to do.
Personally I love
to see that we've
got that support in there.
And that's where the tiny
titan that slipped through.
That wasn't intentional.
I think we later just sort
of having fun and laughing
at ourselves we went ahead
released a ultimate team card
pack that allowed you to unlock
that as an intentional bug.
But the original case, it was
actually another one of those
we make a change and in our
excitement about getting that
change out to our
gamers, we move fast,
maybe don't have all the
processes in place that we
should've.
Someone does some rough testing,
looks good, push it out,
and something slips through.
But it's a big game.
When you start talking
about that program testing
and verification and
validation, there
are so many different
permutations
that have to be covered.
So many different modes.
It's not infinite, but it's
a very large finite number.
And it's almost impossible
to test everything,
which is why we're
trying to start
to get to a lot more
rigor in our testing
and how we measure and verify
that everything is on track.
Let's go ahead and take a break.
And I think, like I said, if you
have a question that you just
want to ask individually,
I'll be here
to talk a little bit longer.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: So the
clock says 2:08.
Back in this room at 2:18.
We're going to give you
time to start planning.
You're going to run two tests.
And then you're going to
have a little bit of time
to reflect on your test
and just a really quick
tell us what you learned today.
OK, it's 2:18 or thereabouts.
Schedule for today is
you've got about 15 minutes
to do planning.
That means you should
know what observations
you're going to make when
you're doing these tests.
If you're going to do questions,
either creating a quick survey
or having questions you're
going to ask your testers.
Just like we asked
for last time.
You're going to spend 30
minutes doing a play test.
That means you're
going to set up
at least three computers
with three observers
to run those tests.
At 3:05 I'm going
to say, hey, switch.
That means anybody who's
doing an observation
is switching with the people
who are doing testing.
Everyone should have a chance
to both observe and play
at least three or four games.
That lasts for
another 30 minutes.
At 3:35, you're going
to time in teams
to complete your
focus test reports.
And then we'll just
ask you a few questions
about what you observed, but
no formal presentation today.
We just want to kind of
know what you saw today.
Questions?
All right.
So I'm going to yell at
2:35 to have your play
tests ready to start by 2:35.